e
we will open the February 21st working
session of the election law subcommittee
on voter registration and impacts of
nonresident voting uh representative C
would you lead us in the pledge
please aliance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
which it stands one nation under God
indivisible with li and justice for all
thank
you all right uh welcome uh to the
election law subcommittee on voter
registration and impacts of non-resident
voting um I'll just read the mission
statement and then we'll uh talk about
what our agenda is for today or at least
a proposed agenda the mission statement
is the following at the direction of the
chairman of the election law committee
this bipartisan sub committee is tasked
with evaluating consolidating and
reconciling various 2025 house bills
concerning voter registration and the
impacts of non-resident voting
accordingly the subcommittee will review
the proposed legislation with attention
to
constitutionality any necessary
alignment with federal election law and
legal precedence the subcommittee will
consider historical context and
opportunities to clarify current
regulations the subcommittee will issue
a report to summarize its findings
recommendations and the ass signed house
bills were listed in the February 20th
public notice for the subcommittee work
session they're basically the same as um
last week with the one bill that we
um uh
executed um being
removed um and there will be some
additional bills likely coming in the
future weeks as the primary election law
committee uh
hears the different uh bills and is uh
subcommittee
uh and so and in keeping with our
practice if any if the subcommittee
determines that any of the bills under
our consideration can be promptly
returned to the election law committee
we will uh do so um again uh some
aspects of this the subcommittee report
will be due out of the committee on
Friday March 14th and that date will
likely be the subcommittee's final
working
session uh for scheduling purposes I'd
like to ask each subcommittee member to
hold open Fridays from 9:30 to 12:30 uh
excluding next Friday um which is school
vacation week and we may have some
additional working sessions in March so
that the report can be ready by its due
date
um so at this point
um I'd like to
so um there was some plans to listen to
a couple of bills uh in particular
representative Lane who is on the
subcommittee uh was going to go over
House Bill uh
385 um unfortunately uh at the last
minute representative Lane was called
away on County delegation duties and so
will not be able to join us until later
in the uh working session and so we will
um adjust accordingly uh one of my
favorite sayings is blessed are the
flexible they will not be broken and I
will apply that this morning so uh one
of the things that uh we're considering
in the mission statement is uh legal
precedence and I think there's uh
possibly two main ones that
are
um are germine to what we're looking
well there's there's a lot of them
obviously but um and election law always
seems to be
litigated um uh but the two that I I
think I that are uh maybe perhaps most
current and most interesting to us uh uh
are the 2018 opinion from the New
Hampshire Supreme Court Supreme Court of
New Hampshire and then the uh
2020 case of uh Caroline Casey versus
the New Hampshire Secretary of State um
there were in in my and I'm not a lawyer
so so I apologize to the lawyers who are
present in this room uh so uh but I will
I will go over this in my kind of humble
way and try to explain as I understand
it basically there are two questions
that the uh New Hampshire House of
Representatives and the
Senate
uh uh through the governor and the
executive Council requested the judges
give their opinions on um a couple of
following questions from the law
and
um and those are those two questions
I'll just
for whoever might be listening to this
uh by subjecting the first question is
by subjecting those who are domiciled in
New Hampshire for voting purposes to the
same Le legal requirements as those for
residents in New Hampshire including but
not limited to the requirements to take
actions required by rsas
26145 and
26335 and to pay any fee which our uh uh
motor uh vehicle registration and
driver's license um and to pay any fees
or taxes associated therewith with House
Bill 1264 on its face folate any of the
following provisions of the New
Hampshire or United States constitutions
they ask about the equal protection
Clause the voting uh article in the New
Hampshire Constitution and the equal uh
equal protection
Clause um in the
federal uh
or United States Constitution the 14th
Amendment of the United States
Constitution um
and then the second so and then to to my
understanding they their initial
opinions are that these do
not
um uh necessarily violate any of those
those uh clauses I can be corrected
later as necessary but U then by subject
the second question is by subjecting
those who are doin soled in New
Hampshire for voting purposes to the
same legal requirements as those who are
residents in New Hampshire including but
not limited to the requirements to take
actions therewith would House Bill uh to
take
actions required by rsas 26145 and
26335 pay fees or tax taxes associated
therewith with House Bill 1264 is
applied to students attending a
postsecondary institution within the
state of New Hampshire Who currently
claims New Hampshire as their domicile
for voting purposes but do not but who
do not claim New Hampshire as their
residents violate any of the following
provisions of the New Hampshire or
United States Constitution and again
they talk about the equal protection
Clause under part one Article 2 of the
New Hampshire
Constitution part one article 11 of the
New Hampshire Constitution and then the
equal protection Clause under the 14th
Amendment to the United States
Constitution and
um again in in reading this um it it
appears
that
um so it says
um interestingly enough uh I won't
summarize the pages and Pages uh that
are in between but
um they uh respectfully asked to be
excused from answering the first
question
um and then
uh they go on to say um and and
ostensibly because there was without
there was no developed factual record um
and then they say they're unable to
answer the second question as well so um
that that but they've G gone through a
lot of different discussions about uh
pertinent law and legal precedence then
um
in uh 2019 there was a case filed By
Carolyn Casey against the New Hampshire
Secretary of
State and
um uh fortunately we have uh to to our
uh pleasure uh Mr Clement totz from the
ACLU who actually spoke for the oral
arguments on behalf of the uh plaintiffs
I believe correct is that correct and um
and so this this particular case had uh
five questions that they were trying to
address
and and
so
uh uh just to give a uh macro view first
they they answer the first they answer
four of the five
questions um in the affirmative and then
they uh decline or
uh exercise discretion to decline the
answer to question
three and um again because it's
not
uh quote determinative of the cause then
pending in any in the certifying court
so it again I um to the best of my
understanding that means that it at the
moment was not uh germine or directly
applicable again I'm not a lawyer so I I
can be corrected on that later by Mr
Clement tot say needed um so just to
cover the questions here in this 2020
decision um are the definitions of
residents resident and residents in RSA
216 and 6-a as recently amended
effectively the same as a definition of
domicile as used in RSA 651
such that the one with a New Hampshire
dool is necessarily A New Hampshire
resident the answer was affirmative for
that the second question was is a
student who claims a New Hampshire doile
pursuant to RSA
6541 a which is the qualifications for
voting necessarily A New Hampshire
resident of under RSA 216 as recently
amended again that is answered in Casey
versus the Secretary of State as
affirmative by the Supreme Court of New
Hampshire um and then in the fourth qu
I'll skip the third question since the
justices decided uh to decline answering
that then the fourth question is
relatedly does an individual who claims
a New Hampshire domicile pursuant to
voting under RSA
6541 Roman numeral 1 or Roman numeral 1-
a necessarily establish a Bonafide
residency for the purposes of RSA 21 uh
RSA
26145 and 26335 which are again um
drivers license and motor vehicle
registration morning and then um so that
was answered in the affirmative and then
lastly the fifth question is uh given
the definition of non-resident in 250
[Music]
967 uh Roman numeral 1 for the M Motor
Vehicle Code are college students who
reside in New Hampshire for more than
six months in any year required to
obtain New Hampshire driver's licenses
by RSA
263 colon 1 if they wish to drive in the
state and required by RSA 26140 to
register in New Hampshire any Vehicles
they keep in the state again this was
answered in the
affirmative so as as I understand it um
and I hope to be corrected by our uh
esteemed colleagues and uh attendees
here this morning
um you would have uh
potentially students or other other
other individuals as well who are
domiciled who then if they choose to
vote inactivate or
activate um kind of their residency and
then at that point they must comply with
the residency requirements in New
Hampshire um and and one of which is
includes the uh driver's license and
motor and the other Motor Vehicle
Registration they in fact own the
vehicle they're driving here um so
obviously these uh we want to avoid U
lawsuits and and
exercise
uh as much uh wisdom as we can in
creating
these uh legislations affecting election
law so we're trying to make sure that we
properly understand the legal precedence
and uh consider them as we go through
our list of bills and uh make
recommendations back to the main
election law
committee
um welcome uh secretary scandin and uh
uh thank you for coming today and uh
also Mr Clement totz from the ACLU
appreciate that um we had um in case you
missed the earlier uh introduction we
had expected to go through a one of the
longer bills for an extended period of
time but representative Lane is uh uh
fulfilling some County delegation duties
at the moment and so we'll not be
joining us until probably 11 o'clock so
um I would be happy to invite um the
secretary uh to comment on on my
understanding of this so far if if you
choose to do so or um if if
uh you know uh welcome it's always good
to see you thank you Mr chairman and
members of the subcommittee uh I didn't
hear everything that you were saying but
you know the tail and what I picked up
was you're talking about college
students and and residency and you know
the statute should
apply independently whether a a person
is a college student or not
and and but when a person registers to
vote in New Hampshire they are claiming
that New Hampshire is their
domicile residence and so the the laws
that apply to Residents then would also
apply to college students who choose to
vote in New Hampshire the the laws uh
and I believe the courts have said
clearly that college students do get to
make that choice um they
can register to vote in the community
that they are living in while they're
going to
college uh and claim residency there or
they can continue to vote from the
community that they came from uh before
they attended College whether it's in
the state of New Hampshire or in some
other state
um and so I think that distinction is
important is that the law should not you
know Target college students you know in
the in the in the uh
um us using the terminology related to
residency and
domicile you know whether instate
tuition is going to be granted and stuff
to to Res you know that's that's a
separate issue yeah yes thank thank you
I I only mentioned the college students
in in reference to the definition under
Roman numeral 1A where specifically
talks about college students that's the
context so and I wasn't um trying to
focus on excluding but M merely
mentioning college students in the
context of that definition so uh but
thank you for that
clarification so I don't know if there's
any questions that the committee has for
me
so I I think
just my understanding is that once
it does that uh decision
[Music]
to um vote and and which at which point
uh dool and residency kick in is does
that occur at the moment uh of
registration or does it occur at the
moment when a vote is cast I know that
te technically a a a person has
established their residency or domicile
before they register to vote because
that is a condition of registration so
that that could happen uh the day that a
person goes to register to vote uh or
there could have been some event prior
to that that would uh that would
okay uh does the subcommittee have any
questions
moment representative c um thank you for
taking my question I'm just wondering of
all the various bills that we have this
year uh have you noticed any that deal
with other issues
involving
um um being a
students I guess we do have that one
people um well I know there's there's
there are a lot of bills that have have
been filed this year and we're keeping
track of them as they come up um but if
there's one that you specifically are
interested in I can try and answer
questions about that I I was just
looking more in general as to what you
may have observed in in your in the
process of you going through various
bills MH whether there was anything that
the well again there are a lot of bills
that have been filed and you know a lot
of them are
addressing specific parts of the
statute and a lot of them are related to
the Integrity of the election
process and uh I think the committee is
doing a good job and and the
subcommittee is certainly helpful of
trying to consolidate the different
ideas that are out there that are
similar in nature bringing them together
and trying to formulate you know a
policy uh from those and but I can tell
you that um in my office we have been we
have been working on uh a lot of things
that we think will bring
transparency uh and confidence to the
process and but they are going to take
some time to accomplish and I I think
that we
should try and understand you know what
that plan is and and how it will uh
benefit the voters of New Hampshire
especially those that are concerned
about you know things related to
technology and you know whether people
uh are appropriately registered and
things like that
um as opposed to just inserting a bunch
of uh uh
extraneous pieces of legislation that
may impact you know the overall plan of
trying to get to where I think we need
to be and so we're following that and
you know when appropriate we'll speak up
and let you know when you know we think
you know some legislation although well
intended May conflict with you know the
there okay thank you uh thank you for
that um if I could I'd also like to just
ask um a brief question
about absentee ballots um and that that
process
so when absentee ballots are
requested I I know in the in the request
form that there's a check mark that says
you have to uh prove that or I am a
registered voter I mean they acknowledge
that the voter registration and so
ostensibly um if they're registered all
the qualifications have been
appropriately addressed already in terms
of citizenship and all
those other
aspects
um
[Music]
are it so the the question is when a
do the Abs does the absentee voter have
to go through the same sort of
identification scrutiny that a election
day voter would have to go through in
terms of um you know presenting
identification or something to that
extent um could would you mind
bit so the absentee voting process
is is a a statute that creates an
opportunity for voters who are
qualified to be able to vote by
absentee if they meet uh the
Constitutional requirements to be able
to vote by absentee which is uh whether
a person is absent or whether a person
has a
disability and then the legislature uh
over the years years uh and and more
recently have added uh Provisions to
that that kind of further identify what
absence or disability means and so they
uh you know there's a provision in there
now that provides for uh if a person is
uh working during the entire time that
the polls are open uh which would
include caring for children infirm
adults um that that's considered a form
of absence that prevents the person from
getting to the polls and so they can
vote by absentee
um there's a provision uh in the statute
now that allows for uh individuals that
are concerned about a severe weather
event I think specifically related to
snowstorms that if they believe that
their uh safety is compromised by you
know the storm that's going to be
rolling through that that could be
considered a form of a
disability um that provision was widely
used during the pandemic uh when we had
a a major Public Health crisis that you
know people were concerned about
catching a a serious uh disease if they
went out in public um and so you know
for that time period or that
election uh that provision the statute
was was expanded I think by Statute and
executive order to allow an increase in
absentee
voting with that
said um this
the the requirements of uh identity
related to absentee voting are not the
same as um showing up in person and
having to show an idea I don't believe
that there's a requirement at the moment
that requires a person to send a copy of
a driver's license or something like
that with a request for an absentee
ballot
historically the
voter had to sign a an application for
an absentee ballot and then once the
voter receives the absentee ballot and
they they they mark it they put it in uh
the what we call the inner envelope also
known known as an affidavit envelope and
they had to sign that and send it back
in and and for a while the moderator was
required I I think the language is
probably still in the statute that said
that the the moderator would compare the
signatures on the Affidavit of the
containing the ballot envelope
containing the ballot and the
application and if it looked like the
signatures were a match then that ballot
would be counted uh there was a loss
suit uh that challenged that uh by an
individual that you know claimed that
you know their signature could vary uh
daytoday and and the judge agreed that
you know a person's
signature uh did not
necessarily uh have to be the same
as as on both documents the application
and the affidavit
envelope and based on that said that you
know unless the moderator is you know an
expert in handwriting and signature
comparison that that could no longer be
a reason to
disqualify an absentee ballot so as long
as the names were the same on the
application and the uh affidavit
envelope and uh as long as there wasn't
a signature that was missing on one of
those documents it doesn't matter
whether it looks like two different
people sign the the document as long as
the signature is there uh and it's the
same name uh the moderator is required
to accept that that ballot so that
really was the check that was in place
um on you know trying to make sure that
um you know the person that requested
the absentee ballot was the same one
that filled it out and set it back uh
that is no longer there and so um
you know I I think that this that part
of the statute needs some work to come
up with a process that does give
confidence to other voters out there
that you know the same people requesting
the ballot are the ones that are filling
it out and signing
it yeah uh yes um thank you I've noticed
that just in uh researching this Factor
there are several states that do require
notary publics and uh public notaries or
um and it seems to
me that there could be
a
a a series of of
um options you know if you identify
yourself to an election a town clerk or
election official or then you know if
you are then a way and cannot do that
identification then you have a notary
public or as we would have in the uaba
uh for military uh maybe military sign
off of some nature I believe that's uh
part of the federal things might have to
double check that
so
um I I agree I think it does
it it could use some work because there
it it seems as if we have a a um
qualification to vote process and then a
check-in verification process for an El
for an election day uh voter but not
quite the equivalent for an
absentee ballot in terms of maybe the
verification for check-in so that um it
would be good to kind of make those on a
as best we can on a Level Playing
Field
um
so thank yeah thank you for responding
to that uh
question are there any uh representative
Burnham thank you thank you for taking
my question secretary skanland um do you
have a recommendation or have seen other
states or
anything that may come across that might
be a better process to accept and
validate absentee ballot
voters the answer is I I don't have a
suggestion at the moment it's certainly
something that I'm willing to look into
and you know work with you know members
of the committee on uh to come up with a
reasonable way to you know to to to give
that confidence um I think being on the
committee you've heard me talk about the
tension between between making voting
reasonably easy uh but also uh you know
having the the procedures in place to
give confidence that the people
participating uh are qualified is really
important you know we can't make it too
difficult uh so that
we're we're creating a situation where
qualified people just aren't reasonably
able to exercise their right to vote and
and absentee voting by its nature uh
does contain a block of individuals that
you know may have difficulty accessing
let's say notaries you know if they're
confined to their house or something and
and so I think we have to be careful and
sensitive to um just making sure that
you know whatever the requirements are
are
reasonable um but there should be an
expectation on the part of the voter
that you know that they should be able
to provide that confidence uh that's
requested so um you know I don't have a
solution uh but I'm I'm happy to work
one thank
you Mr new or represent of new thank you
um as you discussed that balance between
confidence and ability to vote where do
you think we sort of stand on that
Continuum currently under current
statutes and policies are we in the
right place is it sort of diminishing
marginal returns if we go one way versus
the other or what what's your opinion on
that my opinion is that we've been on
the side of being uh too easy to vote
um and and you know that is reflected in
uh you know some of the voter Integrity
movements and the legislation that you
know we've seen to try and pull pull it
back in the other direction um you know
I think that the
um you know the bill that passed last
year that got rid of the affidavit uh
process uh to um to be able to register
to
vote is a reflection of that and you
know up until that bill passed I mean a
person uh and before the the affidavit
bill passed before that um a person
could walk into the polling place
without any documentation and through
the use of
affidavits uh could have established
their
qualifications and and and then
proceeded to vote uh on Election
Day and that's a very easy open process
but it
does form the question in some people's
minds you know how do I know that those
people that just filled out affidavits
are actually qualified to vote and that
and that's a very fair question you know
any any voter in the state has the right
to know who's
participating in the election process
and that those individuals are qualified
and so when when
uh you know I think it's fair that those
people question that process of being
able to establish everything uh uh by
affidavit the legislature and its wisdom
is
pulled back pretty strongly in a
different direction from that um you
know I think that that uh that statute
as it was passed is very rigid and that
there may be people that are
impacted uh because they are qualified
voters but may not have uh ready access
to one of the documents that might be
required uh to prove those
qualifications
there are a couple of court cases that
are pending related to that bill
passing and
I and I think that um there's also some
legislation in that I think would temper
uh what passed last year uh a little bit
so I think the legislature is going
through this process right now where
they're trying to you know pull back on
the statute the way it had been um and
trying to find what that equilibrium is
that thank you um that's very helpful
for me as a as a new representative here
um I'm not sure if it would be your
office or the Attorney General's office
would be the better party to ask but how
many
voter criminal either fraud or other um
whether it's an improper voter
non-citizen fraudulent ID anything like
that how many cases on average a year do
state the Attorney General's office is
the one that prosecutes those cases but
but there
are less than a handful every election
that they find where there was an
appropriate voting activity that took
place um I have not seen
anything uh that they have come up with
that is organized or or widespread uh
but they they do find isolated instances
voting thank you secretary scan for
taking my question uh do you have any
idea of uh approximately how many people
who uh request an absentee ballot
I I don't have numbers on that I'm just
I'm thinking you know is there a way
that we could figure that out um I'm not
sure but but I will see if I can get
some information for you on that okay I
was just wondering because I know some
people um essentially come in to the
clerk's
office building in a application for
absentee ballot get the absentee ballot
fill that out turn it in while they're
still there at the clerk's office
voting and that does happen yes um I
think and the laws have changed so much
over the last few years that I mean at
one time there was a provision in the
statute and it may still be there that
in that situation would allow the voter
to present photo ID uh at the time of uh
you know filling out the ballot at the
clerk's office and then the clerk would
be allowed to put verified voter uh on
the envelope so that uh a moderator
would know that person had shown an ID
process I I would Echo that process I
know on in previous years in business
travel when I've been anticipating being
away during uh election day
and uh over overseas and would be unable
to vote I I know I've gone into the Town
Clerk and have filled out the
application or the uh ballot at on that
day and and again showed my driver's
license in that case um and
would would you know
offhand uh
I'm asking for numbers that are probably
impossible to remember so I apologize
but um approximately how many absentee
ballot applications come through the
Secretary of State's office versus
local um towns or city
Wards I would say almost all of them go
directly to the local town clerk that's
the
process I
I'm not aware of anything in statute
that would uh that
would require the Secretary of State to
receive an absentee ballot application
from a voter if it does happen it's
probably just confusion on the part of
the voter about where to send it and if
we receive if if we were to receive an
application in our office for a town we
would simply forward it to the town
clerk
okay thank
you um are there any additional
subcommittee so I'll be around for a
little bit if you have more we we do
appreciate that and I'm sure um uh
deputy secretary Hennessy last week
popped up several times so we we
appreciate your patience with us and
your ability to stick around as it were
um
Mr Clement totz would you like to
uh come up and testify on some of the
topics that you've heard discussed this
morning I'd be happy to my name is Henry
clemento I'm the deputy legal director
of the ACU of New Hampshire it's nice to
see you all um I thought what I would do
is start by talking a little bit about
the residency and domicile distinction
that you talked about and then the
signature mismatching which my office
was also involved in and then talk talk
sort of at the end more broadly about
other constitutional considerations that
the committee might want to think about
um the subcommittee and I'm happy to be
dragged off topic or answer any
questions at any time um I'm here to I'm
here to help um so
initially I think there's been a lot of
confusion in New Hampshire over the
years about the terms residence and
domicile um the Constitution used uses
the word inhabitant as to who's entitled
to vote and at some point the
legislature in statute defined doile
when basically every other state used
the word resident and I think I can
probably speak for everyone in the room
when I say I wish that hadn't happened
because it just unnecessarily caused
confusion and um so for a
time uh the definitions of domicile and
residents were in statute were different
and they still use different words and
in fact there's many definitions of
resident in the New Hampshire statutes
there's 216 which is the general
definition there's a separate definition
in DMV there's one in the New Hampshire
Aeronautics act I had to go through all
of this when we were doing um our case
uh but but they're generally very
similar but there may be a word or two
that's that's different and so in 2018
the legislature as you pointed out was
considering hb1
1264 which would have removed and and
prior to that the key distinction
between domicile and residence was that
residency required an intent to remain
in the state indefinitely and doile did
not and the legislature was considering
removing that and the governor and
Council asked for an advisory opinion as
he pointed out from the New Hampshire
Supreme Court as to whether that was
constitutional the court in a 3-2
opinion said it was but opinion of the
justices cases like that these advisory
opinions are not considered binding
precedent in the way that other cases
are because as the court itself has
acknowledged it doesn't have a factual
record before it and so they've
described it as they're not sitting as a
court they're rather sitting as advisers
to a co-equal branch of government and
so well it shows the Court's thinking on
it it doesn't definitively resolve the
issue so so that happened the court
returned its answer the governor signed
the bill and on behalf of two delightful
young women we challenged the the bill
in federal court um ultimately what
proceeded in that Federal litigation was
I think people realized and and the
federal judge realized that there was
some actually a lot of confusion over
whether in fact now that the intent
remain def indefinitely piece had been
removed um the doile and residents in
fact mean the same thing did they cover
the same group of people in other words
because it turns out if you go through
the
legislative op I'll call it a Thicket of
residents and non-residents in the DMV
statutes it's pretty confusing and I
actually had to consult a
linguist um at Dartmouth to help me
figure out what part of speech the word
as was in one of the statutes because it
turns out it can be like five parts of
speech so um ultimately in Casey versus
flare so so the federal court certified
that to the New Hampshire Supreme Court
and said in essence do residents in
doile now mean the same thing and if you
vote in New Hampshire do you now have to
domesticate
your car registration and license and
what the court said was
yes um with one I think important
asteris that I think Bears on the
discussion from last week that I was
able to listen to a little bit which is
that you're only required if you vote in
New Hampshire to get a New Hampshire
driver's license if you drive in the
state and so there is a category of
people or there may be who are licensed
drivers and were licensed in another
state who then moved to New Hampshire
and register to vote here but for
whatever reason don't drive either they
don't bring a car with them because
they're attending school or they're
elderly and don't feel safe driving or
they you know live in downtown Portsmith
and don't need to drive and so for those
people they're under no obligation to
domesticate their driver's license
because they're not acting as licensed
drivers everyone else has 60 days from
when they establish do missiles SL
residents to domesticate their driver's
license and if they don't they're
subject on a first offense to a $60
moving vehicle fine and the way that
this is considered by the statutes is
that that's it's it's not a crime it's a
violation but it's a it's a roadway
violation it's not an election law
violation because it's not that you are
an unregistered voter or an unqualified
voter it's simply that you didn't update
your license as is required by DMV rules
I think the fine escalates to over $100
for second events I think it's probably
rarely enforced but the way I could
Envision it doing being enforced at this
juncture is someone gets pulled over
they present an outof state ID the
police officer asked them do you vote in
town yes when did you registered a vote
and they and they say and it was more
than 60 days ago now the police officer
probably has probable cause to write
them that ticket so that's how I think
this they'd have to have committed
another driving offense to get pulled
over in the first place but I I think
that's how this could go down the other
important thing to remember is that
there are people who in New Hampshire
who drive cars that are not their own uh
and you're not under any obligation to
register someone else's car on the state
obviously in fact you can't because you
don't own it so for a while when I was a
younger man I my parents own my car and
so I would not be able to register it
somewhere else because it's not my car
and so there are people who come to the
state with their parents' cars or a
family members car and so they're not
under any obligation to to register it
it turns out and this was uncovered in
the casy case that there's actually
another category of people which is
people who are not registered not
residents of New Hampshire and not
domiciled in New Hampshire but still
spend six months out of the Year here or
more they are not qualified to vote but
are nonetheless re required to
domesticate their car registration which
is sort of an interesting wrinkle that I
didn't think about and that's I don't
know who that is I guess snowbirds Maybe
Who
consider their civic home to be in
Florida but have a car I don't know
people who fly back and forth may not
take their cars and so they have to
register the car in New Hampshire even
if they're not qualified to vote here so
that's sort of an interesting thing and
I think it points out that actually
there's a reason why DMV res you know
requirements and voting requirements are
not quite the same because you may have
two homes and you may have two cars and
they may be in different places those
people are only allowed to vote once but
if they have two cars they may have to
register them and different places
they're still only allowed one driver's
license but it's not quite as simple as
it may appear on first blush would it
have made everyone's life easier I think
if in the beginning the legislature had
simply said residency and doile are the
same probably but that's now happened
they used different terms in the statute
but the New Hampshire Supreme Court has
said that they're the same so that's
sort of the the residency in doile piece
one other fun fact about this case is
that one of the people who I represent
in Caroline Casey who's absolutely
wonderful got so much out of this
experience she went to law school and is
now a three at Harvard which I think is
really fun um so some good comes out of
these cases even if it causes headaches
for all involved um on the signature
mismatching piece so that the secretary
talked about that's a case called CEO
versus Garder which my office did
before um I joined but I can talk a
little bit about it and so
ultimately as the secretary said there
there's a process in statute where the
moderator looks at the signature on the
absentee ballot request form and they
look at the signature on the affidavit
envelope that goes in between the
affidavit ballot and the mailing
envelope and they compare them and the
court enjoined that for a couple reasons
and then there were some other reasons
that we Advanced that the court found it
didn't need to reach number one people
weren't being given sufficient notice
that this was going to happen or most
importantly an opportunity to cure so
because could you repeat the last an
opportunity to cure cure oh thank you
yes so um at the time and I I can't
remember honestly where we are on
pre-processing but AB absentee ballots
are processed on Election Day and so if
the moderator had determined that the
signatures didn't match there was no
opportunity to contact the voter and say
hey we're rejecting your ballot for this
reason and if there had been maybe the
voter would be able to come in and say
no no no that that was my ballot uh the
the other part is that there was
um really very little guidance given to
the moderators on how to do this and so
it was being applied unevenly across the
state and so you had some precincts
where like 5% of absentee ballots were
being rejected and some precincts where
it was zero and it was sort of luck of
the draw on who the moderator was in
terms of how strict they were on
signatures or what they thought their
role was in the process and so it
created this uneven enforcement problem
which is the type of thing that was was
ruled unconstitutional in Bush versus
Gore and then the third issue that the
secretary said is that um moderators are
just simply not handwriting analysis
experts and there's some discussion
interestingly I I was told that the
judge from the bench when she was
adjudicating this case pointed out that
she's ambidextrous and could sign with
both hands and her signatures might look
different and the voters weren't told
that their signatures had to match um
also people who were were talking of
course about absentee voters and that
includes a large segment of people with
disabilities including writing
disabilities and you were allowed under
the statute to have somebody sign for
you if you couldn't and there was
no way for the voter to know that that
person assisting them with the signature
needed to be the same person so like if
you couldn't sign it and you asked your
son to to sign for you on one form and
your daughter to sign for you on the
other the signatures aren't going to
match you didn't know that there was any
reason why that needed to happen and so
your ballot is going to be discarded so
that's sort of the reason why the
signature mismatching case wasn't joined
I'll point out that the the state did
not appeal that
decision um then sort of to to your
question representative weary Mr
chairman about um the identity
verification process for uh
absentee ballots it I believe that
secretary is right that it it isn't the
same process that an in-person voter has
but I would point out that if a person
had their vote stolen by an absentee
vote we would know so say I say somebody
pretended to be me I'm gonna pick on Mr
O'Brien uh because I know him please do
on behalf of the subit yes so so say Mr
O'Brien for some reason decided that he
wanted to impersonate me and steal my
vote and he sent an absentee ballot
request and he said my name is Henry
Clement hoage I live at 244 Marcy Street
in ports New Hampshire do your yeah I
don't care I'm out there um uh my
address is public record on the
checklist
um uh and and got that absentee ballot
filled it out and nailed it back number
one he's be committing a crime several
crimes felonies that would disqualify
him from voting in New Hampshire forever
under the Constitution and could lead to
him going to prison but in addition when
I then showed up to vote later that day
I'd already be checked off and I would
know and so we would know that this was
happening because you'd have a bunch of
irate people or some irate people
saying why am I checked off on the
checklist as noted as voting absentee I
didn't vote absentee but that hasn't
happened so we know that this isn't that
type of big problem because we're not
seeing that um and this is like a nice
transition to talk about the general
constitutional concerns that this
committee probably wants to think about
about so there's a lot of different
parts of the Constitution the US
Constitution and the State Constitution
that govern the voting process so in CEO
which is the signature mismatching case
that was ultimately an equal protection
and due process challenge which is BR
broader than the Voting Rights realm
it's just you can't Target specific
classes of people and you have to give
people the opportunity to prove
themselves and secure government rights
including voting but there's also a
specific framework that talks about how
court evaluate voting laws called the
Anderson bdick framework and it's a say
uh Anderson berdick Anders oh berdick
yes we've seen a reference to that in
many of the court cases sure so there's
two cases yep US Supreme Court cases
that together establish this framework
and basically it's a sliding scale and
I'm just going to try to summarize it
for you um where the court first looks
at the type of Burden imposed on the
right to vote and there's a spectrum
from
uh a reasonable and non-discriminatory
burden all the way up to a severe or
discriminatory burden and then depending
on how intense the burden is the state's
interest to justify it changes from
something close to rational basis review
which is it just is there a reason to do
it and does it plausibly make sense all
the way up to strict scrutiny which is
is there a compelling State interest
than is the law narrowly tailored to
address it and so that's the type of
framework that courts use when add
addressing these challenges and so in
the context of requiring say a notary
for absentee ballots one of the things
that the court is going to look at is to
say okay well the group of people who
are impacted by this we know as the
secretary said are people who are
disabled and may not be able to leave
the house may not have access to a
notary notaries aren't always free you
can go to the I think go to the bank and
you know get something notorized but it
costs
$5 um uh so so that's the burden how
intense is it that would have to be
proven by live testimony from you know
someone like me would go out and find
those people and and ask them and then
submit affidavits and say like I I can't
leave my house like to get a notary or
or whatever it is then it would be
balanced against the state interests and
one of the things that that this people
representing Mr scanland would come in
and say and I'm I'm sorry it's always
you um but that's what the law requires
um
is you know what's the what's the state
interest what are we trying to do and so
number one they'd have to come in and
and probably be forced to admit that
there's as far as I'm aware no
documented cases of absentee ballot
fraud in New Hampshire so what's the
magnitude of the problem that they're
trying to solve how pervasive is it
that's a consideration the court would
make and then another thing that I think
they look at is like does an requiring a
notary actually solve the problem um and
so I'm thinking back and this is a
recollection and so it's take it for
what it is but um I vaguely recall there
was a case
of the only affidavit fraud absentee
ballot fraud case I can think of
involved a person who had requested an
absentee ballot like two weeks before an
election and then passed and their
spouse said and I'm using spouse because
I don't remember the genders of the
people said my spouse had told me they
wanted to vote for cand at a it was like
their last dying wish and they didn't
make it and so the spouse filled it out
and mailed it
back that type of thing where AB an
absentee ballot is sent to the right
house with the right voter and then
filled out by someone else in the
household I would surmise would be the
most common type of absentee ballot
fraud and would not be solved by any of
the bills under consideration because
you have the real voter requesting the
ballot and sending it back
it
would but there's there's no matter what
you do unless you require people to film
themselves filling out the ballot which
I think would be unconstitutional for
other reasons you're never going to be
able to ensure that the person who's
requested the ballot and the person who
filled out the ballot are exactly the
same person if that makes sense and and
so I think that infirmity would harm the
state's defense of these types of laws
because the courts I would argue are
going to have to exact a pretty
significant scrutiny on this given the
magnitude of the burdens imposed and
figure out is the law proposed does it
actually solve the problem and that's
that's just something for the committee
to
consider
um I've spoken a lot I'm happy to take
any
questions uh thank you yeah
um I I do I do have some questions um if
I may uh but
um for the purposes of voting those
those uh you you mentioned that there
were uh individuals who had moved from
other states um who chose to no longer
Drive uh or were uh infirm or for
whatever reason no longer chose
to
uh act on their driving privileges or
capabilities what
um it seems to me that in some cases we
certainly
recognize in statute that if a person
is here in New Hampshire and has a
driver's license and they're over a
certain age I think we're we're actually
trying to change that to 75 now because
65 is of course way too young um my
parents would agree with you what what's
that my parents would agree with well
and and um uh uh the chair is also over
65 so um um I still think of myself as
young even if not everyone does um and
so
if in those circumstances
where uh they have a an old driver's
license from Maine or wherever Florida
um and if they were here and
voting is it reasonable for New
Hampshire to say okay after a certain
period of time we expect you to get
another identification there are
non-driving identifications that are
available from New Hampshire
so what's your concerns with that so
it's an interesting question um and I'm
just going to sort of spot think at you
if that's okay
so if you don't drive in New Hampshire
you're under no obligation to have a
driver's license and in general you're
under no obligation to have any photo ID
at all um if you want to vote you're
going to need I I don't love voter ID I
don't think that's a surprise to people
but I I think that maybe the ship is
sailed on that
um so if you're not under any obligation
to get a new
ID and you move here from so say you
renew your main driver license mhm and I
don't know maybe it's good for 5 years
so then you move to New Hampshire and
you decide not to drive well so you've
got this main driver's license I don't
know whether main Law requires you to
notify them that you are no longer a
resident there there may be some states
that do actually I think New Hampshire
is one where if you move out of the
state I think you're supposed to tell
DMV yes I doubt that happens but um and
like surrender your driver's license but
but in the
scenario say M doesn't require you to
not notify them so you've got a photo ID
that's been issued to you you're
probably not allowed to renew it in
Maine because you don't live there
anymore you don't have to get a New
Hampshire driver's license because you
don't drive there's no legal obligation
for you to get a New Hampshire non-
drivers ID and it may be burdensome to
do it they're not free and you have to
go to
DMV um maybe you have no other reason to
do it because the only reason you need
your ID is to vote I don't know maybe
maybe once your old license expires
probably what the law would require you
to do if you wanted to continue proving
your identity would be to get a
new non- drivers ID in New
Hampshire when you now need an
ID I don't know I I guess I think why
should we be requiring people to do that
if they're
not if the only reason that they're
getting an ID is to vote
then you're sort of tying now the
burdens of getting the non-d drivers ID
even more discreetly to the voting
process and so that makes it closer to
like not a pole tax necessarily but but
now you're spending the $50 or whatever
it is to get a non- driver's ID solely
for the privilege of voting is it
reasonable for the state I don't know I
mean I think that would be up to a
federal judge
um uh I'm inclined to say no because
because there's no
I it's one thing to say you need to
present a current ID but to say you have
to if you have a driver's license that
otherwise
counts and it's you're not driving
anymore what what's the state's interest
in requiring you to get a new ID I guess
answer so the the burden
of so o overtime
uh people age and and their appearances
can change radically even y um and so a
driver's license that had a fiveyear
expiration date that that is now a year
past its expiration date y um very well
the person could uh May resemble but but
you know not entirely match that
identification credentials being
provided by you know out of state
licenses so that's an interesting
question and and I think what I'd say to
that is actually if a close reading my
my reading of the statute is that when
the person checks in to vote and they
present the photo id the the ballot
clerk is not actually comparing the
person's picture to the person I don't
think that there's any legal requirement
that you look like the picture on your
ID you're comparing the name it has to
have a photo but people transition
genders people grow or shave beard they
cut their hair they dye their hair they
get glasses as you say they're you know
they get in a car accident and become
you know just look
different I don't think that there's any
obligation and if there were then it
would be every time you dye your hair do
you have to get a new driver's license I
mean that that's I think that sort of
shows the problem with that but but
right now under New Hampshire law I
don't understand New Hampshire law to
require anyone to actually verify the
picture on the person you're you're
presenting an ID with your name on it
and the picture and the reason for that
is like why would anyone carry around an
ID with someone else's name and picture
on it and if they do they're committing
a whole host of other crimes um if
they're trying to you know do identity
fraud but but the picture piece isn't
isn't what's there you're right it's not
in Statue I think by practice I often
observe that the supervisors of the
checklist on Election Day are looking at
the picture and looking at the person uh
quite of
I volunteer as a ballot clerk in
Portsmith I don't do
that you have remarkable discipline what
um
so uh all right well so th I think that
is an those are some interesting
questions that I think the election law
committee should wrestle with and the
subcommittee will try and wrestle with
some of that
um with with regard to the question it's
been raised that there's not much of a
incident of fraud detected for some of
this
I it's my understanding you know the
attorney general has a lot of different
responsibilities not solely being
election law and so I'm wondering if the
resources um are
are sufficient um you we have a few
cases you know it's not as if there's an
active investigation into
every um problem or
issue that that is being acknowledged or
reported I I think
so you'd have to ask them about the
their resources and obviously the
allocation of government dollars is a is
a is a New Hampshire legislative
determination to make um I can just say
from my experience there is a dedicated
election law unit at the Attorney
General's office there's an Assistant
Attorney General
in charge of it who I hold in very high
esteem there's an investigator there who
I hold in very high esteem I think this
is basically all that they do whether
there should be more of them is a
decision for you all but but um there
are people who do this and they look at
it and it's not like it's not like the
attorney general just is doing this and
a million other things they there are
there is a dedicated unit and they are
but as I said I hold them in high esteem
I've litigated against them they're
people and I've called them um what what
when issues arise right for for
clarification purposes yes uh
enforcement um are there any other
questions from the
subcommittee at this
point
represent thank you Mr chairman um thank
you for taking my question kind of I
have a scenario uh we were talking about
out of state license so firsttime voter
yeah um firsttime voter with an out
ofate
license um appears to
the um checkin or uh with
a information of one residency where
their vehicle is registered yeah and
then has
another document indicating The
Residency which is in a different part
of the same city within New Hampshire I
doing this so three different
identifications one photo ID driver's
license from an outside of state and two
separate um pieces of document from two
different residency first- time voter so
they get a pass basically they can come
in and vote with that information is
that
correct um so I'm going to quibble with
your isation of them getting a pass but
I will but yes and and
um so doile and
residency the way I think about it is
that there's an objective component and
a subjective component so you have to
have a p physical presence in the state
of New Hampshire that's the objective
piece and it has to be and I'm I'm
paraphrasing for memory but like your
primary place for civic and social
participation in Democratic
self-government and so so I think that
there's a mental component to that of
like a person has to decide in their
head where their Community
is and there's a few ways that a person
can do it and it has to match up with
whatever objective facts there are on
the ground so there's no requirement for
example that a person spend 60 six
months out of the year in New Hampshire
or even a majority of their time in New
Hampshire it just has to be like where
you would do jury duty where you would
vote where you would give to local
candidates where you would go to the
school board meeting those are factors
to consider under the current statutes
as they exist and and they're being
challenged in court there's no more
affidavits to prove any of your
qualifications so when this person goes
to register to vote they will have to
prove to the satisfaction of the
supervisors of the checklist that
they're domiciled in the town or Ward
that they're registering of v in so that
could be with a lease it could be with a
utility bill it could be that they
appear on a list of people who have a
dorm at Dartmouth College in the town of
Hanover um or some other document that
is to the satisfaction of the
supervisors of the checklist but it's
not I would say that they're getting a
pass it's that
they're presenting documentary proof
that they live in that town and and I'll
say to your point that I I think that
probably the most common type of voter
fraud and I'm not I haven't done an
exhaustive review of this it's sort of
anecdotal but I think that the most
common type of voter fraud in New
Hampshire probably is double voting and
so that probably appears when people
have multiple domiciles not multiple
domiciles but multiple houses so a
person lives in Massachusetts but they
have a ski condo in New Hampshire or
whatever and they decide that they're
going to vote in both places first of
all they're going to get caught but but
second of all they're not going to get
caught because of any of the documentary
requirements because they can prove all
those things they can say I have a deed
to the ski condo I have proof of
residency that the issue is that they're
also voting somewhere else and they'll
get caught when the checklists are
ultimately compared
so you can require documentary proof to
say someone has a connection with a
particular place in New Hampshire which
is what the legislature has done but I
don't know how you can ever get someone
to prove that they don't have other
places or have had other places and it
and one other point I'll just make to to
to
um your scenario is that when you move
within the state of New Hampshire you're
required to update your address with
DMV but you're not required to get a new
physical driver's license and in fact
they're not free so I live in Portsmouth
but if I move to Dober I have to tell
DMV that I'm moving to do but I don't
have to get a new driver's license that
says Dober on it and if I did I have to
pay like
$50 is was that helpful at all yes it is
I I have a follow-up though so the same
person in the scenario if they go to
vote
again with the same credentials they're
already logged into the system what then
happens so they've already registered so
they've already proved to the
satisfaction of the supervisors of the
checklist their age citizenship identity
and domicile they're coming back to the
checkin table and they're voting again
all they're doing now is proving their
identity and so what the law requires is
that they present one of the categories
of documents that include government
issued ID that has both a photograph and
their name and that's all that they're
proving regardless of where the ID is
from which state so they can reuse that
ID from they can and and I see where
you're going with this and I point out
that I think that it's possible given
how late our state primary election is
that you can actually have two elections
within 60 days of each other
um because you could vote like at
September 8th and November 3rd I think
are within 60 days so that that can
happen if they were to do that I suppose
that there there's evidence now that
they've committed a DMV violation by not
domesticating the driver's license if
it's also proven that they've driven
during that period of time and if there
were a police officer around who observe
this they could probably write them a
$60 ticket for failing to update their
license but the mere fact that they
haven't done
that I here's my broader philosophical
response to you if I may is the mere
fact that someone hasn't updated their
license doesn't mean that they're not
domiciled and living in the state it
could just as easily mean that they're
scatterbrained or busy or
disorganized um I lost my driver's
license it just just like fell out of my
wallet and so I went around with my
expired license for like 3 months and
it's just because I have this job and I
have a kid and it's like snowing and I
just didn't get to it should I have I
definitely should have but that doesn't
mean that I wasn't qualified to vote in
New Hampshire so I guess I would
encourage the subcommittee to think
about to hold in their
minds that just because someone doesn't
do these like bureaucratic steps doesn't
mean that they're not actually living in
New Hampshire I understand that there
are competing interest and that people
may have philosophical differences about
how reasonable it is to impose these
burdens on people but I don't know
consider your disorganized nephew
you any additional U representative new
thank you um thanks so much for your uh
explanation especially on residents in
domicile are there issues with
citizenship as well yes yes big time
could you kind of expand on that a
um um there's a there's a rule of
professional conduct for lawyers that
prevent people from talking about
pending litigation with a represented
person without their lawyer presence so
I can't get too into
it um so I'm not going to talk about the
lawsuit but what I'll say is that
currently New Hampshire Law requires
documentary proof of all of your
qualifications including age citizenship
identity and doile from my perspective
citizenship is the hardest qualification
to prove with doile with documents
there's no document I'm aware of that
proves all four some documents can prove
three like a driver's license can prove
your identity domicile and age but it
doesn't prove citizenship a passport can
prove your age identity and citizenship
but not your domicile so so there's no
documents that prove all of them the
documents I'm aware of that prove
citizenship are a birth certificate if
issued within the United States
naturalization
papers and a
passport
um I think the reason that I'm most
concerned about this is that I think
that's the type of documentary proof
that people are least likely to
have um I don't know about the
incidences of citizenship fraud or
non-citizens
participating in our electoral process
but I can just say that those
requirements are under Court challenges
and that there was a 10 circuit case
from 2020 where the 10 Circuit Court of
Appeals in St Louis maybe struck down a
Kansas law that required documentary
proof of citizenship because they found
that something like between 12 and 20%
of people who were registering to vote
were disqualified because they didn't
have documentary proof of citizenship
but the state's own expert testified
that at least 99% of them were in fact
so I don't know if there are any bills
that are under consideration with the
subcommittee that address
citizenship um but one could easily
imagine you know an elderly person who
moves from their house into an assisted
living facility in a different town or
Ward and now has to
re-register may not be able to be found
on the Statewide voter database and when
they re-register now has to prove their
citizenship as well even though they've
been voting in New Hampshire for 70
years and doesn't have an original birth
certificate doesn't know where to get
one and doesn't have a passport and that
person would not be allowed to register
so I do think there are cons I yeah big
concerns
citizenship so the the main concern is
really the proof of the citizenship is
is that
what yes because citizenship is already
established as a legitimate requirement
for voting as I understand it yeah
there's other court cases larger than
what we're talking about that have
established that yeah so there are some
municipalities outside of New Hampshire
that allow non-citizens to vote for
some municipal offices so like I I think
in Maryland and maybe California there
are communities where non-citizens might
be able to vote for school board that's
not the case in New Hampshire right you
have to be a US citizen to vote in New
Hampshire and I'm not advocating that
that
change maybe it could include us
Nationals I don't know I haven't thought
that out
but uh okay thank you thank you for that
answer um
I'd like to just touch on the fraud
question just a moment it it seems as
you were talking about that that most of
the fraud cases are actually people that
are the fraud cases that are identified
are actually people who are double
voting at some level either within New
Hampshire or Massachusetts in New
Hampshire or something like that I think
that's right the Attorney General's
office would be more definitive on that
because they conduct the investigations
and like may have secret investigations
I don't know about but I think that
that's
right I know there I know at least from
the voter I uh Integrity groups often
talk about concerns when there has been
a municipality or a
town of some sort who have had more
votes than voters after an election and
there have been
two uh two communi s that that I'm
familiar with yeah on that matter um
would you care to comment on that or uh
I honestly I would I would direct that
to the secretary sorry to put you on the
spot I don't I don't think that's what's
not um I I guess I don't specifically
know what you're talking about so I
would to someone else that that's a a
fair response um and the CTO versus
Gardener how how do you spell CEO
S no please um um I can pull this up and
site um s a u c d o s CE e d o thank you
yep versus Garder and
that's our own Bill Gardner correct is
that yes yes indeed uh that's a 2018
case from the District of New Hampshire
okay thank you very much yeah we'll
suppose all right I I uh I don't see any
further questions from the subcommittee
at this time thank you very much Mr CL
thank you very much for for uh allowing
me to speak with you it's been we
appreciate that and and uh anyone on
this subcommittee or anyone should feel
free to reach out to me with any email
by questions I'm Henry at aclu.org I'm
happy to answer any questions for the
committee's convenience thank you very
much thank you uh Mr secretary did you
have any follow-up uh comments um after
hearing that testimony and some of the
follow-up questions that the
subcommittee had that you'd like to
comment on I'd offer you that
opportunity at this time yeah I don't
have any followup comments other than
you know the issue of more votes than
voters on the checklist I mean there are
reasons why that happens and after every
election we kind of go through the
return of votes and the moderated
reports just to try and you know figure
out what those discrepancies are it can
be anything
from uh counters not understanding
um that
when TR I think things like when when
the when the ballots go through the
ballot counting device and they get
kicked out for a right in vote that
might be on that ballot sometimes they
think that they have to count every race
on that
ballot and not just the right in so
sometimes we get you know double
counting um in situations like that and
then because we have same day
registration and in some elections there
are very large numbers of
election day
registrant uh the number of votes in
that
election uh may show very high in
relation to the uh number of Voters on
the checklist before you know they add
those into the process so there there
are it's usually human error that causes
that and uh you we do our best to clean
that up after the
election
so uh so if if I may uh just uh ask a
follow-up question to that so uh because
I think that would be very helpful
for uh voter Integrity groups or
whatever to understand that so uh if
there are a large number of same day
registrants there's actually sort of a
lag time for the checklist to catch up
to those additional same day registrant
being added onto the checklist there
there could be just depending on how the
report takes place at the local
level
how how long would that how long would
you anticipate that lag time to
be if if there's a you know if
they're um writing this information in
how how quickly should they be updating
that back to your office hopefully it's
all cleaned up within you know 60 days
but it's a it's it it is a large process
of uh certifying the returns after the
election's over I mean that is done
usually within a week but but sometimes
there are Corrections that are made by
at the local level and that information
trickles in sometimes after you know the
formal process is complete we do make
those adjustments when uh you know when
we become aware that an error has been
made but but um but those are the types
of things that you know cause those uh
numbers to
um you know be the way they are thank
you well that I think that's very
um yes represent sorry uh thank you for
taking my question so the uh supervisor
of the checklist do they have a deadline
as to when they need to update the
firsttime registration voters not first
time but yes same day same day
registration voters is there you said
about 60 days but is there an actual
time period they have to have that
submitted to you I don't believe there
is a hard date in the statute other than
they have to have their checklist ready
before the next election takes place so
in in the case of a town where you have
a state general election in
November uh they have to have their
checklist prepared and ready to go for
March local elections so all of that
work needs to be done cities may take
longer because they most of the Cities
don't have their elections until
November really a year after the
election process from our perspective
it's important to get that information
updated as quickly as possible and you
know and we do request that but there is
no hard deadline for when they have to
have that
done can I have a followup here so would
you prefer to have a date that's a hard
date within certain time
period would that be helpful to the
office your
office well it would be helpful for the
office but but I I am always cognizant
of the workload that is on the local
election officials and you know I don't
want to sometimes they need pushed but
many of them already are working very
hard to get those jobs done and and
they're pretty much volunteers so right
you know we we want to work with them on
you I if I may ask a follow-up question
to that it
would 90 days after a general election
and 60 days after other elections be
appropriate I'm just thinking about the
large volume of Voters that we have
during the November general elections
versus typically a a much lower response
uh or turnout um during the local
elections
be acceptable to the Secretary of
State's office I'm sure the municipal
Association would have something to say
about but
um is that the sort of time frame that
you might be looking for to have uh
checklist
updated instead of having a rigid
deadline I I think it would be
preferable to work with the supervisors
of the
checklist and the clerks just helping
helping to support them in that role so
that they can get it done as quickly as
possible as opposed to because as you
mentioned you elections are all
different local elections lighter
turnout State
primaries certainly lighter turnout than
general
elections and a you know a a general
election without president versus one
where we're voting you know those are
also very different so flexibility I
good all right thank thank you for your
response appreciate that um just just a
quick follow um when you said that they
had to get it by the next election would
an sb2 deliberative session count as
that next election as well yes okay
okay um I think I think we're done here
thank
you
think this has been very helpful to hear
uh perspectives uh this morning
about the kind of legal precedence and
and other concerns with uh both the in
both
um the state interests to have
elections that are safe and secure as
well as you know the burden imposed on
the right to vote so I think those are
really kind of the balancing factors
that we're trying to consider here and
uh really appreciate the testimony from
the Secretary of State's office and from
um I think what I'm going to do is just
um have the committee take a quick break
till maybe
11:15 and then we'll
resume and uh
we'll uh we might have a little Changing
of the Guard I know one of our members
has to leave for some um other community
commitments and we have uh another
representative who is going to be coming
back after uh County delegation
obligations being fulfilled this morning
so um we'll resume at uh 11:15 by my
watch so that is about 12 minutes from
much
e
break for anyone who might be
watching um what I'd like to do
is go over some bills um we we sort of
go gone over some of the legal
precedents this morning looking closely
at uh some recent opinions from the
Supreme Court of New Hampshire
and um uh a case that was litigated in
uh 2019 2020 Casey versus the New
Hampshire Secretary of State and we
heard testimony from the Secretary of
State's office and from the ACLU this
morning regarding different aspects I
think um what struck me was really
trying to find a balance between the
state's interest to have safe and secure
elections versus the burden imposed on
the right to vote I think that is um
sort of
the uh key aspects that at this
committee needs to consider at least one
one of the aspects that the committee
needs to consider is making sure that we
appropriately balanced want those
aspects
now
um I think we have uh last week we
discussed bills pertaining to RSA
65913 there were uh at least four of
them that we
discussed and we as well
as um we worked on one and moved that
along because basically it
had um while some good ideas it was
really addressing the concept of
domicile in the wrong area of the
RSA uh
for now what I'd like to do
at um there's a couple of bills
that there's there's one bill that uh
specifically talks to 65412
365 let me um so I'd like to just
that and then
hopefully uh representative Lane can
come and join us soon and we can go over
385 um but this is this is I think
Germain because this pertains to the
proof of citizenship which we just
discussed with uh Mr Clement toes from
the ACLU so
um if I may just discuss this bill
briefly um it's a a new paragraph voter
identification proof of
citizenship and they were uh inserting a
paragraph two um if a person claiming to
be qualified to vote is unable to
provide reasonable documentation
establishing that the person is a
citizen of the United States um at the
request of such person the supervisors
of the checklist city or town clerk or
authorized election officials shall
attempt to confirm the citizenship
through the office of the Secretary of
State and the Secretary of State can
then make reasonable efforts to
determine if they are a US citizen by
accessing relevant and available inst
State out of state and federal databases
that contain such
information um however if the request to
verify citizen status is made on
Election
Day um neither local election officials
nor the Secretary of State shall be
required to expend such time or effort
on citizen verification as would
unreasonably interfere with other
election day duties if the unit if the
person's United States citizenship
citizenship is verified they shall
notify the uh the Secretary of State
shall notify the local election official
and the citizenship criteria for voting
shall be deemed satisfied the local
official shall then note on the person's
voter registration application form US
citizenship verified and shall indicate
on that form the date and the basis on
which such verification is made so I
think just that's the first part before
I continue on with paragraph B I
think um that looks to be a fairly
clear balance between
um trying to meet the state interest for
for the qualifications of the voter but
wi
without imposing an unreasonable burden
on the person who has that right to vote
perspective the uh then Part B um just
continuing on if a person claiming to be
qualified to vote asserts that she is
unable to do due to indigency to provide
documentation to establish that he or
she is a United States citizen and if
efforts to verify the person's
citizenship pursuant to sub paragraph a
are not
successful the city or the town clerk or
the Secretary of State May request such
a person to complete a financial
affidavit on a form developed for this
Purpose By the secretary of state so
if a person um does not have the
resources or wherewithal to be able to
pursue documentation of citizenship then
they may make a uh appropriate
application and then uh if based on
criteria established by the Secretary of
State appears that the person qualifies
as Indigent the clerk or secretary or
the secretary May provide the person
with a voucher sufficient to cover the
cost for the person to obtain a
certified copy of the person's birth
certificate or other equivalent
documentation to establish that status
as a United States
citizen uh the person shall be
specifically informed that is the
person's responsibility to communicate
with the appropriate Vital Records
agency in the state of the person's
birth and use the funds provided through
the voucher to pay any required fee to
obtain the person's birth certificate or
equivalent proof of citizenship such
documentation shall be provide to the
local election officials on before the
day of election in order for the person
to satisfy the citizenship criteria for
voting and then the Secretary of State
shall reimburse local municipalities for
the cost of all vouchers issued by the
city or town clerks pursuant to the sub
paragraph
so um and then the rest of it is
concerning financial matters which we
will not go into at this uh for this
subcommittee
so from that perspective I think that um
again is trying to ease what might be
perceived as an unreasonable
burden
um imposed on the right to vote um
certainly this makes Provisions to make
it much easier for an Indigent person
to
um obtain the information as
needed if it cannot be obtained under
the uh aspects as mentioned in par sub
paragraph
a um
so any comments or thoughts on this on
this particular house bill at this
point represent Jameson thank you
um
um it's hard to say where to start on on
this because
um
it's first off I guess we heard
overwhelming testimony against this bill
in about a ratio of 10 to one against um
including all the online
submissions um the inperson
testimony uh we did not hear from the
sponsor about this bill at all so it's
hard to say there was no there was no
give and take uh questioning there
um the aspect of an affidavit saying I'm
poor is
I find it hard to believe that we would
accept an affidavit saying I'm poor but
not accept one saying I'm a citizen and
able to
vote um and qualified is one issue I
have with that another one is
that um the voucher programs we heard
testimony that it would really only be
applicable to folks who were born in New
Hampshire which is we heard it was about
a third of New Hampshire um voters were
born here and almost 80% of women's
birth certificate doesn't match their
name uh when they get married and change
their name so query whether that proves
their
citizenship
um that then they would need another
document possibly which would be the
Merit certificate um or SEC or uh Social
Security documents showing the name
change which then adds more and more
costs and burden
um to do that um and the LA well the
last thing that's coming to my mind at
this point in time is that this
basically I think would kill same day
registration um and if we want to do
that that's a policy decision but this
is not the way to to do that um in that
it does provide that yes you can do it
on the same day but there's no way that
the secretary of state would I think be
able to handle the requests uh to make
that happen and as we all know Justice
delayed is Justice denied so if we have
a a a plan in place that then prevents
somebody from same day
registration um that is not
workable on that same day they would be
denied the right to vote
unnecessarily
um so this there there's all kinds of
problems I find with this
um with this bill
um
so representative Burnham do you have
comments Mr chairman yes um I don't
recall like how is this an issue like do
we see many of these issues where an
Indigent needs proof of citizenship like
I'm just trying to understand where is
coming from do we can you help me with
that have we I believe this is in
response to last session's uh House Bill
1569 which took away
the um ability to swear under penalties
of perjury that you are a US
citizen um and it's trying to fix that
aspect of it is
my belief but I'm not 100% sure I see
it's in response to a bill from last
session yeah yeah it is it is an House
Bill 1569 I believe um I think there's
they're trying to
clarify the requirements for sit for the
proof of citizenship so just again to to
reiterate um there is already well
established in and this was part of the
conversation with Mr Clement toits is
there is already a wellestablished
requirement that uh for citizenship
um and so the uh in in order to vote in
elections and New Hampshire unlike some
other states does not
allow um non-citizens to
vote having so that is
a a
[Music]
proper qualification for a voter in New
the issue at hand then becomes not is
that qualification improper but does the
proof of that qualification by the voter
impose an undue
hardship um versus uh the state interest
to keep elections safe and secure by
making sure that in fact that person is
indeed a citizen
so
obviously there there is this is a
process of refining exactly how we can
best
find uh I think someone used the term
Sweet Spot um balance uh
between that requirement to document
citizenship versus the efforts required
to provide that documentation so uh I
think that that is what this bill is is
attempting to do um and has made
a and has tried to
anticipate if P if a person may have
difficulty providing that due to a
resource aspect of some sort uh we think
about
um you know may maybe uh there are
homeless populations and other uh people
who may have those sorts of issues um at
that time so I think that's what this
bill is attempting to do I think I
appreciate your comments representative
Newsome
on um the challenges that you see with
this particular bill I think those
um uh the Committees the election law
committee will certainly have to
consider that as on once uh from an uh
executive session standpoint and and
then we should consider some of those
aspects in our reports as as well from
the
subcommittee and I'd also be willing to
bet that that is the subject of the
lawsuits that uh Mr Clem to was not able
to discuss discuss I i' I'm not 100%
sure but I'd be willing to bet that is
that that uh 1569 is the subject matter
of those so I'm sure we'll see guidance
branch indeed perhaps uh perhaps one
never knows um and we we will the
subcommittee will not attempt to uh
forecast the future so nor should we
wait and on those results exactly uh
we'll leave that to other other folks to
do so but I would also like to just add
that I do agree with you that uh
citizenship is a
required element of registering to vote
and and is a valid State concern I I I I
just wanted to say that I'm not
disagreeing with you on that so I we we
are in agreement on at least one thing
right I'm sure as uh the as the public
should know is indeed um the majority
and minority parties agree on probably
70 to 80% of the legislation um
unfortunately it's the the disagreements
that make the news and uh therefore
that's what the public hears about the
most um but in in fact there's much that
we agree on so but I appreciate the
recognition of the agreement on
citizenship qualification so thank you
for that um all
right
um representative Lane has not joined us
but I I do really feel compelled uh to
some degree to start uh in on what is
our longest bill um which is RSA
654 uh which is I'm sorry H House Bill
385 of which there are a number of
different sections within the bill
pertaining to uh multiple parts of the
RSA so um I I did just get a text from
her saying she left about three or four
minutes ago from her County meeting okay
which is just the county offices are
just down the road so I would anticipate
her AR Ral shortly depending on where
she Parks okay uh yes um good point uh
let's then
um go
[Music]
to uh let's look
at if we
may
um we'll look
at 217 which I think really parallels
some of our discussion from two from
365 um if we have time um we may do one
other quick bill and then by by that
time I'm sure representative Lane will
be here and we can go over the
um
uh uh 385 at that point so let's let's
look at 217 um I'll just uh describe
that briefly
for uh whoever is listening so this has
to do with the absence registration
affidavit so
uh as this subcommittee has talked about
there are really two processes that
we're concerned about is uh one is
registration the other is uh receiving
The Ballot or obtaining the ballot uh
which on Election Day is the check-in
process but uh of course for the
absentee ballot um that varies a little
bit we heard some testimony from the
Secretary of State on that this morning
so let me just go over that so this has
us amending RSA
65417 to read as
follows um it shall be prepared the
registration absentee registration
affidavit shall be prepared by the
Secretary of State and
shall uh contain uh I'll paraphrase
contain the following
information
uh they uh attest that they they attest
to a series of things um and uh swear or
affirm under the penalties of voter
fraud they attest that they are one a
citizen of the United States uh they
establish their legal domicile is in a
town or city I'll be uh age proper
voting age on uh election day and
entitled to vote in the election to be
held in in said town on such and such a
date um except for the fact
that uh that the name does not yet
appear on the checklist to be used in
the said town at such election so they
essentially are not yet registered and
are attempting to register and obtain uh
absentee ballot all right goes on
um uh stating their absence
um in part two I I do not intend to be
present within said town at such time
prior to said election that will allow
that person to appear before the
supervisors of the
checklist and uh in their regular
sessions for the correction of the
checklist for set election so the
process is if you're registering the
supervisors of the checklist normally
have these sessions where you can go in
and register with them and uh
and so if you're anticipating voting in
the next election you can go in and
register with the supervisors of the
checklist but if you are absent how do
you do that um and uh so this allows
that process to occur and then they
explain their temporary
temporarily uh temporarily residing in
um city and state or city province and
Country um
and then
they uh enclose copies of the doc
documentation required by RSA
65412 um again the qualifications to
vote that establish citizenship age
domicile and
identity as qualifications to vote and
then they acknowledge that if they do
not provide a copy as required of the
documentation as required by section
for above the
application uh shall not be
approved and and then they I hereby make
application for this so this this is
really for the voter who is not yet
registered in a town or city Ward who um
because of their circumstances will be
away from that town or city Ward uh
during the supervisors of the checklist
sessions and therefore will not be able
to pre-register in that manner
and uh of course will also be away
during the election day itself and so
we'll not be able to register on uh by
the same day uh election uh day
registration process so they are
registering by
absentee uh
registration and then uh it goes into
um and B basically the same thing and
they uh next page has basically the same
sort of thing and then it explains why
the ne the next page really covers the
same aspects but then describes uh goes
into some detail in sub paragraph two uh
why they they cannot appear uh before
that um
uh on Election Day so uh and this has to
do primarily with the affidavit for a
physical disability
so
um and then on
the third page this
is the signature of the
witness to support
there are some
other um rsas that are amended as well
uh
65419 the submission effect and um so
and this covers the supporting
documentation when it's provided and
then down in sub paragraph three uh ver
ification of an in-person absentee
voter and then U just talks about
providing voluntarily a photo
identification that meets the
requirements uh voter
verification and
then uh Provisions that if they do not
PR present a qualified photo ID they
will not be treated as a verified
voter um and that that is that so um I
think so this is
um a bill that sort of tries to align
the
uh verification of the voter
qualifications for people
who
cannot um apply in person to the
supervisors of the checklist or will be
absent on the day of voting uh and
therefore not eligible for making or not
present to be able to make a same day
registration in that case so that's what
this uh particular Bill House Bill 2117
pertains
to
um so as we as we've heard I think again
the
the the greatest challenge or hurdle
um is the
documentation for citizenship that we've
that we've heard discussed this morning
so I think that's every most of the rest
of this seems to be fairly
straightforward I think that but that is
the
uh one point that would
be of some concern and how how do we
make sure that
we enable
[Music]
the uh right to vote without creating an
undue
burden any comments from the
subcommittee Welcome representative
Lane sorry for for being late no that um
appreciate the obligations that that uh
Representatives also have as County
delegates um not everyone understands
that so that that's worth uh
mentioning
um so I I I have a question just because
I missed all of this and I haven't had a
chance to watch all this hate but um did
someone speak about citizenship and the
history and I I'm going to watch the
tape so you don't need to tell me but I
just wanted to make sure that somebody
had spoken to it and that everybody had
the information that they needed yeah
okay if I can I'll try and summarize it
as as in in two or three uh sentences is
uh no one questions
the
um the citizen no one questions
citizenship as a qualification for the
right to vote in New
Hampshire that is well established and
uh Mr Clement toes from the ACLU
recognized that and and that's been uh
long settled in other court cases not
not including any of the recent ones
that that are um that Mr Allen
identified in his research memo that
that goes beyond that's a that's long
established um the
what was discussed most
is
the uh some
voters uh will have some
challenges
providing proof of their
citizenship
and while this
um subcommittee does not choose to
speculate on pending leg legislation or
pending uh litigation
um it it's quite possible that some of
the pending let uh litigation discusses
that
um the three documents that provide
proof of citizenship are a birth
certificate naturalization papers a
when there are changes to names because
of marriage or or other things there
might be additional documentation
required a marriage certificate for
example or uh some legal order to change
one's
name
uh and
so one of the discussions that was
talked about was the state has a
legitimate interest to make sure that
their elections are safe and secure that
only qualified voters are
voting um and that is no one contest
that uh the challenge is
then um is an undue
burden being imposed on the right to
vote and
and some burden is
provide those documentate documents as
as needed but um it's an untolerable
burden that is uh I think part of the
question
here and what do you do in certain
circumstances when when people
uh are not able to get uh not able to
immediately provide that
information do we make Provisions for
that
all
right so are there any comments at this
217 I think I I know that I didn't
participate or here but I'm relatively
familiar
um in the United States as a country we
have for years satisfied this by an
affidavit
and on in feder federal elections and in
state elections and now it's become an
issue and I guess I'll ask the Attorney
General this when they come but do we
know that because the penalty
for someone who is not a
citizen to basically lie and say they
are a citizen are severe um not only our
State
penalties but the the fact probably
there's a they violated Federal and they
may well be deported and they probably
will never become a US citizen because
this will be a felony and so they will
not be able to pass the citizenship
requirements
um for naturalization so I guess I I
come back to why do we need this bill a
and you know what is that burden that
you mentioned um you
know what is that because it the the
ramifications of line about this are
it I don't know if anybody I don't know
if anybody talk talked about that before
or that came up in the conversations but
you know those penalties are very I mean
it's like a 5,000 or
$7,000 fee for state level it's a uh I
think it's a felony even in the state
and or at least a misdemeanor and on on
a federal level it's it's even higher
yeah
uh that's a very interesting point I
think um one of the things that was
discussed is that there are some
um not not within New Hampshire but
there are other states that currently
have recently have permitted
non-citizens voting in local
and again hypothetically or
theoretically you could anticipate
someone from that local moving to New
Hampshire and maybe not understanding
that New Hampshire laws are different
and then act upon this I mean as a
hypothetical
only and so um it's not out of the realm
of
the border control issues
with um people coming into the US
without maybe the normal
controls uh I think there was a concern
that there might be people who would
voting people who who would be illegal
immigrants would
have uh maybe less of a qualm of
voting um since they're here illegally
but and I I think that's that's sort of
the rationale for or that's the concern
I've heard expressed is that
if someone is here illegally then the
threat of deportation is does not
increase with voting and you can
actually
influence
uh elections in your
favor
um uh really really with no change to
current consequences so that again we're
talking hypothetical so
right and I also would if I was that
person I think you'd be more likely to
be found if you're giving if you're
registering and you're providing first
of all you'd have to get a fake you'd
have to get a fake ID you'd have to get
a lot of fake stuff and then you're
going to go on and you're going to be on
the rolles with an address so if
somebody wanted to come and Deport you
you've kind of just raised a red flag
said here I am so in some ways maybe
they don't even they even have less of
incentive but and I guess it comes down
to in my mind when you talk about these
theoretical problems I think somebody
testified that there was nine% uh don't
of the population generally don't have
these documents readily available and we
had a lot of testimony before about that
too I think was maybe it was last year I
don't remember but is it I guess the
question comes down to is is it worth
saving those maybe five or six people
who come in and and try and and keep out
9% of our voters I mean is that and
that's to me when you talked about the
balance or the burden you know how many
people are you willing to disenfranchise
in order to catch a theoretical person
vote and as just framing it that that's
how I think about it it's like how many
people do we disenfranchise before we
is uh is
there so you you've already said that
you you do agree that citizenship is a
is a qual with so right and it has been
um if we if we then
uh have established that we are going to
verify that as a
qualifying or we we will require proof
of
that um and we allow ample
immediately I can I can fill
out um according
to 217 you I will supply this
information
um at at some I guess I would ask at
some
point doesn't this have to
be this this information should be
available at some point
right well well I guess we've gone since
1787 without having it without
undue problems so why not we and we have
an affidavit right now that people have
been signing with no problems and if we
and we have penalties that exist that if
you lie you know then there's a big
penalty so in my
mind why require somebody to come I mean
first of all it takes months
right and to get naturalization papers
is very expensive I mean people have
tossed around numbers like $500 $600 to
get them
and and yet they're Lo you're we're
having them lose their most important
right um because they can't find these
papers I mean and not everyone not
everyone has easy access to a lot of
stuff so part ofy says if you catch
somebody and we have lots of people
watching the poll and the Attorney
General's staff is there watching the
polls and we have moderators checking
people in and if you have an affidavit
and you're swearing on the
affidavit why is that still not good
enough why do we need this extra
documentation when even the federal
it I I think what we've heard um I think
it was Mr Richard who testified that
what we have is is it's not really the
classic legal affidavit but is instead a
self-verification
documentation
document um and that we've actually
moved away from the full legal
definition of an affidavit again i' I'd
have to revie viw my notes on um his
testimony regarding the affidavit but uh
I do believe that there are some people
do who do have some concern
concerns with what the rsas currently
call um an affidavit so right but again
I'd have to I did I I remember his
testimony and what I um I started
looking through the RS the election law
rsas and there's a lot of instances of
affidavits with people swearing under
penalty you know that they first of all
it's penalty of perjury then there's
going to be penalty of of of the um of
the law of the election laws and which
enable them to like it's a
misdemeanor um one's a one is a $5,000
penalty there's a felony and a high and
a criminal and then there's civil and a
I can't remember the exact details but
there's plenty of penalties built in and
we can write an affidavit that would do
that so I would want to look at his
statement because I'm not
sure because we've had these affidavits
and people have been been prosecuted on
these
affidavits um and again when maybe when
we get the Attorney General in here we
can ask them about that but if you're
signing something and saying you're
attesting to and you're affirming and
you're subject to the penalties and
you're signing it whether you have a
witness or not you've signed it you'd
have to prove that it that's not your
signature I mean and somebody's want you
know I I'm not sure
that I want to look at it because I
think you could craft an affidavit that
would
work and that would be much easier for
people to
sign and particularly if they're doing
same day registration they're signing it
in front of somebody after they've
already showed their
identification right do I have the
process they've already showed if we're
doing same day registration they've
showed their ID now they're
proving now they have to prove domicile
and citizenship and these other things
so if they can sign an affidavit as to
citizenship the person who's doing the
same day registration is there in front
of them um and so they and they have
their ID so they can't come back and
claim that wasn't me unless there's a
fake ID and then we have then and then
whoever this person is is going to be
liable for I mean you can throw the book
it it
is so I
I'm I'm just thinking through that
is um if they're able to
[Music]
prove if if they have a proper ID they
can
show uh do evidence of domicile
and
age um
you're what are you saying then with
regard to citizenship sign an affidavit
sign an affidavit right I mean that's
now and then at at what but the
often in in the process where we've had
these affid before you were there
required to provide proof subsequently
you're provide required to provide
evidence within seven days or something
like that if you know in the um
so
at at some point do you not have to
citizenship I've never had
to and I got my birth certificate oh
when I when I got my passport I had to
prove it and the hospital that I was
born in had burned down and so it was an
exercise to find it and it definitely
took me more than a month and it
definitely took me more than a week so
um and I so and I know I mean somebody
testified last year that they uh were
adopted and they had no idea where they
were born and they had no idea where to
to find a birth certificate
and I don't I'm suspecting that's not an
unusual circumstance so again how many
people do we disenfranchise because
we're scared that somebody's going to
come in and commit fraud and again I
want to ask the AG's office you know if
he's aware of anything in New Hampshire
and I guess you know is there are there
PE I'm assuming this must be happening
nationally but where but where is it you
know where is is it happening and and if
it's not really happening then then why
do we need to solve a problem that's not
um it is
um a bit of a dilemma here we here we
have a qualification for which we need
no
evidence uh so that it's an interesting
it's an interesting perspective we have
a qualification for which we need no
evidence well so the evidence is the
person who's signing the affidavit under
law you know and who I I I don't know I
mean to me we've never had to do that in
New
Hampshire since the Constitution was put
in until recently and in that time time
span I don't know Math's not my strong
point so but roughly 200 years we've
never really had a problem so if we've
never really had a problem with the
citizenship piece then why do we need to
make people go through this exercise if
it's not been a problem or if they can't
prove it or they don't have the
documentation then sign an
affidavit and if we really want to go
after people for and if we find out
they've not voted correctly or they're
not a citz listen because there's my
understanding there's no one place that
you can go in the federal government to
find out if somebody is a US citizen and
we ran into this last year when we were
trying to do bills because I think it
was Senator gray who wanted to rely on
federal databases to prove this but then
it came
out during the hearing that there's
really nowhere to do that I mean if that
was something that was easy to do sure
you can verify it but right now that's
not something that's easy to do and not
everybody not all the supervisors can
get to that Statewide or that Federal
database on on the election day because
of connectivity issues right right and
actually I think um House Bill 217 does
address that aspect because there you
they recognize that there would be
concerns with election day duties as
well
that that trying
to uh close the loop on the evidence of
citizenship in on an election day is
something that would
be uh
overly burdensome for the election
officials because of their duties and so
therefore uh there were allowances to um
cure is not probably the correct term
so
um all right so I think that's
um we may actually have the evidence of
citizenship may actually be a good
question for our esteemed
researcher um so I will uh Mr Allen um
uh
I I will try and craft a well- worded uh
question to you and uh ask for some you
to research uh if there are other states
that are requiring this sort of evidence
of citizenship and what are the
provisions I will gladly rely on
somebody's better research than mine but
a quick Google search has showed that
there's eight only eight states require
proof of citizenship one of which Kansas
is is not being enforced because of a
court decision so we are in the extreme
extreme minority of states there well
as yes and and uh New Hampshire is is uh
as was mentioned earlier has its own
unique aspects we are included as one of
those eight states on this list saying
that we require firsttime voters to
present proof of citizenship when
registering so we are included in that
list of eight as in that Minority of of
States yes that was in HB 1569 which was
year all right so we will uh I will
craft a a
um question for our researcher to to
look into that
and
um see what see what we can find
well and uh just for the record the
for conference state legislators yeah
that's what so
um that's that's you that's a good place
to start just for comparison but so
um
um you might you might get a couple of
requests coming out as well so uh
representative Lane
um well we have we only have 20 minutes
and I'm um it's already
um uh
128 by my watch 128 so
uh I'm I'm reluctant to have you cover a
19 Page House bill um in I'd give you
one minute per page uh okay but
uh
um uh do
you would you prefer that we cover it on
uh March
7th yes okay yes but I can say and I can
sent I think I sent to you the sections
of the rcas that were Affiliated and the
short version of this is that it
repeals 1569 and puts everything back
the way it was before HB 1569 passed
which I may be wrong I don't remember
1569 being this extensive I don't think
it was 19 Pages was it all we did well
ol yes it was that's why we were not
happy with it but um we um and if it
does if it does more that was not the
intent the intent was to appeal it and
so what OS did was go back to the
statutes
before 1569 was enacted and put the back
undid okay that so just so theoretically
if if I took 1569 and took this bill I
could go you should be able to okay and
if if there's a mistake then we can talk
about that but um yeah no no because I I
can blame OS but that's not really fair
because you know I'm in charge of right
the buck stops here yep exactly um and
yes they were crunched and yes this was
a huge thing but they did an amazing job
they really were very good on this
because this was not a easy lift so uh
so just as a assignment for the
subcommittee then is is in the
intervening two weeks let's go through
I'll go house bill 1569 from last year
and then House Bill 384 is 3 38585 yeah
and um go through and do a comparison
make sure that there was
nothing
um no surprises I guess worked in and it
was truly a taking it a a true repeal
where it was taking it back to the
wording it was established beforehand um
because that will be simpler to
um address and
explain
um and discuss if if we know that as the
basis for our discussion right and and
it would be understandable because the I
forget the exact timing but the timing
between the governor approving it I
think I had one day left to file a bill
so if there is an
error I wouldn't be necessarily
surprised giving the rush but we felt it
was important to um because it had been
anticipated he was going to veto it and
then he approved it and so we had I
think one day to
file right right so that's why I'm just
saying it would not necessarily surprise
me if we find a few snafus okay but
uh I I think this committee on you know
for uh this subcommittee uh should
should do that as part of the um under
our scope of responsibility so that we
can report back up to the to the main
committee any uh discrepancies we might
find with that premise that you outlined
and then um again I'm I'm sure after our
discussions we'll we'll have interesting
reports to uh give back to both a
majority Minority Report to send up to
the ELC as a
whole um as to what our recommendations
might
be and so how how should I get the list
of all the statutes all the sections
affected to everybody is that something
that you can send to the subcommittee I
don't want to violate um 391 issues so
uh I can what if I read them out yeah
why don't you read them out and then
that way that way people can look at
them and it's in the record and it's in
the record and and we can um then uh you
know start the discussion on the 7eventh
and we'll go into it in in detail and
and see what if everyone has done their
proper homework we'll we'll see what I'm
sorry what people are uh finding out in
terms of the comparison Okay so go ahead
please all right so um
654 colon 12 is on page
654 colon 7 is on page
7 654 colon 7- a is on page
14 659 colon 27 is also on page
14 659 colon 27-a is on page
15 659 colon 13 Roman numeral 1
parentheses small C is Page
65913 Roman numeral 2 parentheses B
through e are on page 18 and the last
one is five Colon 6-d D Roman numeral 2
and that's on page
19 can you repeat that last one uh uh
five colon
6-d as in dog Roman numeral 2 thank you
so the the last RSA that you mentioned
is not within the election law it's five
no no I and I can't remember exactly but
it was in representative L lens bill so
I I can't remember which one that I can
up yeah it's it's interesting it's not
the same uh RSA statutes that Define
resent or residency so um and they were
we didn't hear that in our discussion
it's a cross reference chapter five is
Department of State yeah so it'll
probably be a secretary of state it
it it it's a reference to the Hava Hava
act hav so I think that that so it has
to do with Hava yes and there was a
cross reference that they put in or took
out I can't remember now but that's it's
okay right so there yeah probably some
Provisions under Hava that we need to
make sure we address
so all
is there at this point I don't think uh
because of the time we only have about
11 minutes left or so um I'll just ask
um the subcommittee if there are any
further comments and if not we'll we'll
um uh end today's working session again
I think we've had a lot of testimony
today on the legal precedence and some
of the history behind that
and some discussions
about
uh doile and residency and and how they
are now essentially the
on
uh uh 28 I believe it was 2018 House
Bill 1264 as well as subsequent court
cases um the 2020 decision of Casey
versus uh Secretary of
State and a number
of uh four questions were answered
regarding that and and so again anyone
who
um has should wants to follow up on that
that would be uh I think important to
understand that that's
uh I certainly think one of the Hallmark
cases that we need to consider as we
um try and summarize uh positions on
this so I'll just go around the room
um uh representative Nome any uh
comments or considerations for this
subcommittee
um at this point I'm gonna say I think
we've covered it and we still have a lot
of work to do ahead and look forward to
getting into the nitty-gritty and
looking at some of the broader policy
considerations um as we go forward and
applying those policy
considerations to create consistent
Fair um and
achieving the goal of secure elections
thank you thank you representative Nome
representative Burnham any uh comments
subcommittee I do not have any comments
or questions but um it's been very
informative having um guests here to
explain um certain procedures and things
like that so I think that's going to
help us to determine what we need to do
do moving forward I guess that's my
you thank you representative Burnham uh
representative Lane I know you're a late
entry here but um and you still have
some uh video watching to do yes but um
are there any comments or considerations
you'd like to offer I would just Echo
representative new's
comments all right duly noted thank you
very
much all right
um so at this point we will meet again
on March 7th we will not be meeting next
week um I will send a request or two out
to our researcher Mr Allen um certainly
one
regarding uh which states require
evidence of citizenship what do they
require and are there any relevant court
cases that we know about but I'll I'll
put that in an email to you Mr Alan
thank you and uh I have some other
questions as well with some interesting
questions
about
um public notaries were raised
today and uh in the context of I believe
absentee
voters so we may uh I may have some
questions along that line
too um all right well I want to thank
everyone yes oh just one other thing um
just wanted to double check that you
would be inviting uh the elections uh
law Bureau from or whatever they're
called from the Attorney General's
office yes I um uh deputy secretary
Hennessy was kind enough to provide a
contact person great for that
um
um uh we will see if they respond so
invitations are one thing attendance is
another right yes it is unfortunately
yeah this is it's not a subpoena that's
for sure so um we get maybe we could
just we could come up with list of
questions
um um so actually that's a that's a
great suggestion if there
is um a list of question if people on
the subcommittee I'll send a note to
representative C but if there are a
series of questions that we would want
to present to the Attorney General's
office um regarding election law why
don't we come up with those and then
if
um if
those we can uh discuss them and if if
the Attorney General office cannot uh
come by by the 7th um maybe we can send
them ahead of
we'll see we'll see if we need to have
another uh quick in uh uh quick meeting
with the subcommittee to um pardon me to
meet with them to meet with them yeah so
we'll we'll see we'll see what can be
done but um all right well thank thank
you everyone and um have a wonderful uh
week